want to share this tweet with our  viewers that is just coming our way it's  a little bit small so I'll read it for  you from supporting British businesses  to lowering the tax burden for the  lowest paid our growth plan sets out a  new approach to build a more prosperous  economy however it is clear that the  abolition of the 45p tax rate has become  a distraction from our overriding  mission to tackle the challenges facing  our country as a result I'm announcing  we are not proceeding with the abolition  of the 45p tax rate we get it and we  have listened this will allow us to  focus on delivering the major parts of  our growth package and then he goes on  to talk about the growth package but  basically we get it we have listened is  what he's saying so it's been left to  the chancellor to do the u-turn